there's nobody quite like our guest
tonight that has been proven by science
joining us now from high atop Shaq
Mountain the one and only Shaquille
O'Neal how you doing jack I'm good about
yourself
I've had better weeks for sure you're in
Las Vegas now yes sir
yeah how are you feeling what are your
thoughts about you haven't unique
perspective not just as a black American
but you also have law-enforcement
training you worked as I think an
auxiliary sheriff you at one time talked
about running for sheriff I think some
members of your family your uncle was it
was a police officer what do you think
when you you turn on the television yeah
there's all saying that that goes what's
right is right what's wrong this wrong
and what happened to George Floyd was
all the way wrong absolutely wrong
uncalled for
I have never seen that that technique
talk a lot of police officers I talked
to would never do that everybody's upset
everybody's tired we demand justice you
know they try to appease us by arresting
one guy well it was four officers out
there and I think people are just sick
and tired I've been I'm 48 years old
I've seen you know outbreaks and rise
before this is the first time I think
the country is doing it all at the same
time never seen more than one city it's
just that just said you know we're tired
you know that's - we're just you know
people that are standing up for people
especially the young african-americans
that they just hired they want they want
equality that they want justice and I
understand I do understand I'm all for
peaceful protesting I don't like the
opportunists that are riding around the
neighborhoods leaving bricks trying to
cause riots I don't like people breaking
into stores I don't condone all that but
I am for peaceful protest and that I am
for justice and the mayor of the middle
of the governor of Minnesota
these two needs to do something I think
the other three guys need to be arrested
I think that that that's all the family
is looking for
but you know like you said earlier
you've had better weeks I've also had
better weeks I don't like to see the
country like this which we had somebody
in the leadership position in the White
House that would bring people together
not come on and say I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna do that really miss Obama
I think he would have handled this
situation with with class and with honor
he would have definitely did the right
thing but my condolences to the Floyd's
family I never met mr. Floyd but I'm
good friends with one his best friend
Steven Jackson and according to Steve
and he was a great man
so now anybody from the engine area have
always been great to me
you know the Beaumont area Texas area
I'm from San Antonio so you know when I
watched the video I was disgusted I can
you have your knee on the man's neck for
more than five minutes it just didn't
you know it just didn't make any sense
and you know police officers you know
when you're not training that you know
better you have to know better in you
know certain situations and you know
there's a it's a chief of police friend
of mine who was an academy with me art
Acevedo in Houston what he can't
marching with the people that was a
great thing I was a kid you know yeah I
was actually in the police academy
together so I saw him speak yesterday
and he had some really great things to
say and you wish that there were more
art Acevedo's out there when you hear
him speak yes this is you know the
police and the community is at our
all-time all-time high of being apart
when I was coming up to policing you
know we had community policing you know
everybody loved and respected police but
you know when you have situations like
this not has to be able but you know
we're just looking for justice that's
all Chad did you have the talk that we
now hear about I think is something that
most white people weren't really aware
of the talk that you have to have with
your son's about dealing with the police
and being extra careful yes I have the I
had that talk with him all the time I
tell them I tell them first of all you
have to try to defuse the situation by
showing respect because you have to
understand that these
while also out of year to do it doing
their job so you try to defuse the
situation and if it happens to get rough
don't say anything don't do anything
just comply and then when all was said
and done you called me and if stuff gets
out of hand then I will handle it I will
be the one that come out of attackers I
don't want you to act crazy while you
got there by yourself so I just retreat
you know just try to tell them but just
comply to just listen but a lot of times
that doesn't work either so you know I
checked how do you know try to be real
with them and have you know certain
certain conversation but you know from
the videos I say would miss the floor
and he was compliant I've seen three
different videos I saw one video they
had him on a wall he wasn't talking back
he wasn't struggling I saw another video
in the car you know appears to be they
were roughing him up and in the last
video I see I see officer with his knee
on his neck so that's not supposed to
happen but I have this conversation with
my son's all the time but but I also
tell them that you know just show
respect you know where with Shaquille
O'Neal we'll be right back more with
Shaq when we return
[Music]
[Music]
that is a sleeping Shaquille O'Neal as
posted by his son Sharif on tick tock
did Sharif ask you before he posted that
or just put it up I've never seen that
before in my life so it sounds like over
there mowing the lawn or something no I
was probably after one of my hard
workout days you know Shaq that would
make a great commercial for your coffee
company for toe you know you guys are
doing something for health care workers
and weirdly and sadly it seems like
kovat has become a sub story to what
we've been seeing right now but of
course these people are still out there
and this could actually get a lot worth
weren't you and Fort Ord a ting a
million shots to frontline workers of
coffee yes a million Coffee Shasta
frontline workers because we we
understand we love and respect that you
guys have been working hard hours you've
been underpaid overworked well you know
with with our prodigal for Oh give you a
energy chef so I think in 33 states
we've already donated over a hundred
thousand yeah we plan on just you know
giving away 1 million 400 shots to the
frontline workers I wants a total
frontline workers out there thank you
very much you probably don't hear it
hear it enough we love you we respect
you and the world would not be operable
without you guys so we commend you for
your hard work and we appreciate you
check you've also chosen as our charity
tonight the Boys and Girls Club of
America you used to go to the Boys and
Girls Club when you were a kid when you
were a kid right you didn't just come
out a giant no I was actually my mother
tells neck I was 6 6 ounces with 611 I
came up messed up my 6 foot 11 6 pounds
and
oh yeah I would have believed either
yeah I was a very I was a very tiny cute
sexy baby and I'm still very tiny cute
and sexy now did any kid ever try to
fight you at the boys club all the time
really
Oh imagine they must have been older it
could have been anybody your age well
know that we actually actually they were
although they were all older and because
I got bigger I had to fight you know
older guys but it was fun
it actually just you know taught me how
to be fearless and telling me how to be
tough well if you would like to join us
in making a donation go to bgca
dot org that is the Boys and Girls Club
of America I love talking to you I love
seeing you thank you so much for talking
to me tonight I really do appreciate it
all right thanks Shaquille O'Neal we'll
be right back
[Music]